منذ بدايه الغزو الروسي الذي يوشك ان يبلغ
عامه الاول لم تتوانى اوكرانيا في الطلب
المساعده العسكريه من حلفائها الغربيين
الدعم الغربي
من واشنطن عزيزه املها في الحصول على
الطائرات المقاتلات تساعدها في مواجهتها
المحتدمه مع موسكو لكن المساعدات
الامريكيه لكيف لم تصل الى حد تزويدها
بالطائره اف 16
في المتكرره بشان الطائره المقاتله
والصواريخ بعيده المدى لكن الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل لم يستبعد ذلك بينما شدد على
ضروره توفر بعض المعايير لاتخاذ اي قرار
بهذا الشان
لساتني
اذا ما تم احترامه ثلاثه معايير الاول هو
يتم طلب ذلك مع احترامي مواعيد تسليم
والتدريب بنسبه للجيش الاوكراني المعيار
الثاني هو الا تشكل امداداته الاسلحه
عامله صعيد بمعنى ان الامدادات 30 اقدمها
ليجب ان تستخدم لضرب الاراضي الروسيه ولكن
للدفاع عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه المعيار
الثالث هو ان اي امتدات لا يجب ان تؤثر
على قدرات الدفاع الجيش الفرنسي على ارضه
ومواطنه
وكانت دول الغربيه على راسها المانيا
والولايات المتحده قد وافقت اخيرا هذا
الشهر على تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات متطوره
تعد الاقوى في جيوش دول حلف شمال الاطلسي
في وقت اكد فيه الرئيس
الينسكي ان بلاده تواجه وضعا صعبا للغايه
في منطقه دونيه
من الاسلحه لمقاومه الهجمات الروسيه